Speaker 1: OK, so yesterday we did this, Fox
News has gone silent on ivermectin story,
and I explained to you that very early on,
300 plus mentions of ivermectin by Fox News
host saying it's good and people are being
treated by it and is being covered up in
all this different stuff. And then we got
real randomized controlled trials, which,
as Dr. Steven Novella told us, it would sort of be
our gold standard for evidence on medication and
randomized controlled trials, say ivermectin
doesn't work for COVID and would zip their
lips. Fox News and everybody goes completely
silent like it never even happened until
yesterday. This is the next level in gaslighting.
Fox News propagandist Sean Hannity is now saying,
I warned my audience about ivermectin. The studies
don't say that it works. This is such a brazen
rewrite attempt to rewrite history. He can't
be allowed to do it. It's classic revisionist
history, and media matters put together this
great article. Hannity's new lie is that he
warned his audience about ivermectin. We have a
clip which they put together. You're going to hear
Hannity now just a couple of days ago say I was
telling people, there's I don't know about this
ivermectin thing, and then you're going to
hear all the times he talked about ivermectin.
Some of the times check this out,
Speaker 6: by the way that I had. I've been
telling people, Ivermectin, Linda, is that not the
one thing that I kept saying is not a single study
that I've seen that shows that it
Speaker 1: works 100 percent.
Speaker 6: And as well as other proactive
treatments and practices while already helping
COVID 19 patients all across the country.
Speaker 1: Now, when you say ivermectin is
helping COVID patients, you're saying it works.
Speaker 6: Therapeutics, hydroxychloroquine,
ivermectin, Regeneron when you talk about
ivermectin and Regeneron and incredible
therapeutics that are now being used to treat
not just breakthrough cases, but all cases,
that includes, yes, the model colonial cocktail.
Speaker 1: By the way, Marno Colonial is just
one of its it's one of my. It's almost better
than Trump's rum reservoir for rum remdesivir
Speaker 6: as Regeneron, the Eli
Lilly version of Regeneron. Even,
yes, hydroxychloroquine, ivermectin. Listen,
this is my business, so I constantly reading.
They've never heard of Regeneron or ivermectin.
Ivermectin hydroxychloroquine that show that taken
early it can mitigate symptoms of COVID 19.
Speaker 1: When you say ivermectin mitigates
the symptoms of COVID 19, you are
saying it works. You're not saying
in some limited place it seems like it, but
be careful because it's not really a trial.
This is classic revisionist history. They get
through, not Hannity, but in total, Fox gets
more than 300 promotions of ivermectin. They say
not only that it works, but that it's a conspiracy
to prevent it from being used. I mean, going
above and beyond what the evidence shows. And
then Hannity goes, I've been saying, be careful
about this from the start. I said it because we
don't know that it works. This reminds me of when
Trump in 2018. It's a very dystopian line, said,
you can't even believe what you're seeing,
Speaker 3: but it's all working out. And
just remember what you're seeing and what
you're reading is not what's happening, right?
Speaker 1: Even what you see. Is not what's
happening. How do you know what's happening? Well,
Trump tells you. But of course, applied
to Fox News. They told you that ivermectin
worked. They told you that they didn't
want you to know ivermectin worked.
They told you that the pharmaceutical companies
wanted you to get a vaccine instead of ivermectin
or Regeneron for financial reasons, even though
Regeneron is way more profitable than vaccines on
a per regimen basis. And now they're telling you,
I warned you all along, if you had listened to me,
you would have known. There's no evidence. This
is the suspension of disbelief that is required to
buy into this cult, and they're willing to do it,
and they've shown that they're willing to do it.